everybody I've been I've been here a few
times already but this is my first time
lecturing so I'm really excited today
we're going to be talking about opposite
color bishops with heavy pieces on the
board which is a very important
differentiator usually opposite color
bishop's weed out in the endgame is a
factor of what of equality right draw
exactly how about when we add the heavy
pieces on the board for the attack
they're much better for the attacker
there are a factor of improved of
advantage okay so we will see there are
two two factors of assessment when when
we're looking at positions like that one
of them is the difference between the
bishops whichever Bishop is more active
whichever Bishop has more targets to
attack and the other one as you pointed
out is the initiative the player with
the initiative has a great advantage
let's let's go through the game this is
a game between two grandmasters back in
the days in the 1950s Phillip and
pokémon pokémon is actually a guy that
played Fisher a few times I think he has
an equal score out of maybe 10 games so
he's he's quite a talented guy so he was
he was Philip was white Parkman was
Black Knight a 3G 3G six okay how do we
call this set up for white
I think is the ready ready nowadays
that's how they call it actually a lot
of people a lot of top players are
starting to play this it's a very
flexible setup you can adopt a lot of
structures for example you can go with
c4 d3 you can go d4 you can even go
things moves like b3 so very flexible
not a lot of theory and players that
have the confidence that can outplay
anybody used to they play this they play
this a lot D 3 d6 and we've reached some
sort of what type of structure Sicilian
closed Sicilian with with d3 right might
be to night c4 what is why trying to do
but potentially maybe play something
like e 5 open up the center open up his
his light square bishop in the future
not not at the moment where is black
going to attack on the Queen side right
so he played rugby 8 preparing b5
getting away from from this diagonal
it's always a useful move for black a4
basics why didn't he play the move Asics
this seems quite natural
a5 exactly and now b5 is is no longer
possible so always be careful this type
of structural changes basics c3 a6
normal continuation his uh his
continuing with his plan b5 ok we should
be seven how is the structure in this
position guys who has the advantage from
a structural point of view who said
black why
because of this pawn right yes very good
but white can can get something in
return
how very good and that's what he played
if he would have traded on on b7 which
seems like a natural move black takes
he's then going to go Queen d6 rook d8
if this Knight is ever going to go away
from e5 which he probably will
since he doesn't have a lot of support
then the other rule goes to d7 and the
d3 pony ultimately will fall so this is
already a pretty bad position for white
obviously he wasn't he wasn't that weak
so he had a plan in mind he play 96 this
force is black to give away his light
square Bishop Bishop takes c6 95 Queen
b3 b6 very very natural developing moves
right for both sides Rock d8
okay and this is kind of the critical
position of the of the beginning of the
middle game so you guys try to make a
plan for black what is the most kind of
natural way you guys would be inclined
to continue in this position
what is one piece that can be improved
and could potentially become a real
danger for white rockin b8y how right
and potentially she could be she could
become active if the B file opens up
right
or she could scoop over on the a file or
on the default shirt the blue the rockin
B it is quite flexible but there's a
different piece on thinking about and I
think I've heard from the back the
bishop on g7 right this is a very very
important piece for black right now it's
he's facing a wall so the usual plan in
this position should include what before
right
trying to break White's pawn structure
now the question is how are we going to
make that happen
and that is exactly what he did but
that's a bad move we will we will return
to this position in just a second
right now try to find the whites whites
best option to continue the game if you
allow that that dark square Bishop to
get active then you're going to be in
real trouble so try to find a sequence
of moves that could potentially like
keep that guy locked up what are the
candidate moves for for white in this
position Bishop takes d5 is 1 yeah d 4 d
4 can quite easily be refuted I think B
take C and you're having some problems
on the on the B file you could try to
take on c5 but then I can also just take
on b3 you take my queen I take on b2 and
this point is going to promote one way
or the other
yeah so white black is almost winning I
think
so before doesn't really work Bishop
takes d5 yes c4 c4 is actually the
natural move yeah you don't you're you
you're going to keep the B file closed
but c4 also gives away the what square
the d4 square right so let's try to
think a little bit further than that
are we going to be able to contain his
Bishop after c4 or his Bishop is going
to end up on d4 and create a lot of
damage so c4 Knight goes were
where would you like to maybe direct
that night towards what Square D for
right so night goes to East seven and
here is kind of the key move of at least
the first stage of the game
what does Bishop afford do
exactly exactly Bishop f4 is the move
and this is what black missed at the
beginning of his plan when he played
before this Bishop before now if I was
forced otherwise you look you lose the
Rubicon b8 and besides the fact that the
bishop on g7 is locked
also it's highlighted over here the D
Phi square for the for the bishop right
so white got a clear advantage we will
see how he exploited it but let's go
back a little bit in this position if b4
fails because of c4 then Bishop f4 and
and the dark square bishop is still
locked
what should black do to prepare that
rock d8 is is is a move but she pointed
out b5 is hanging and actually you want
that rock on ba on the B file because
after before if you open up the B file
then that rook is going to become super
active
Quinn somewhere yeah Quincy seven you're
still not threatening before because
with the Queen on c7 you're still going
to be on this diagonal Queen somewhere I
would say probably Queen b6
is the best move in this position Queen
b6 then before is coming and to be
honest I believe black is actually
better right now despite the fact that
white is the one with the bishop pair
after disk dark square bishop is going
to become active
it is only black who who who can play
for advantage so he hurried up a little
bit and don't hurry this is this is a
static type of position you have to
change the structure you're not going
for the King right you have to prepare
this type of moves so Queen b6 would
have been the right move
he played before C 497 Bishop before
Bishop e3 Knight to c6 Queen to a4 okay
I want to ask you one questions he he
play 94 but what if black plays rugby
six
or is he threatening in this position
look a seven right rock a seven to get
control of DFL so let's try to stop him
from doing that
let's calculate yeah okay one
interesting move very natural
yes
rokay one obviously black will respond
with 100k seven still wrong case that
one right
how to continue after there
once again let's look for candidate
moves Chris what is the most obvious can
they move queen retreats yeah somewhere
B 3 C 2 D 1 well D 1 actually I think
it's no it's not do you want is still
okay but the problem is if you retreat
your Queen I'm just going to play rook
ba 6 I'm going to get full control of
the a file and then black shouldn't be
worse right anything else any other can
be moved what about just giving the
Queen the way or about just sacrificing
it for the rope and hmm how is the
position afterwards yeah that's the
question
actually I think we need 7 is better
because if you go Queen c6 now actually
you're right Queen c6 is is is a good
move Queen a7 is also a good move let's
say Queen c6 baroque takes c6 only move
what happens if if black tries to take
on a one first
Quincy 8 Queen e8 any of them work
intermediary check and then take the
rookin Europe Issa so he has to take
with the rook on c6 we take on a 7 and
my question for you is how is this
position who has the advantage and why
okay so we have a rock up a rock on a
bishop for a queen yeah d3 is still
hanging sure so that's one target for
the Queen but I will tell you one secret
in this in these positions with
imbalances with material imbalances a
queen for something a rope for two
pieces important the importance of
targets is is is huge so the Queen has
only one target on d3 but that's going
to be easily defended by playing what
move Bishop on d5 right how many targets
do does white have in blacks position
quite a few yeah c5 is one of them but
is not the main one which one is the
main one f7 is definitely the main one
because black doesn't have a
correspondent for for the white square
bishop so you're going to play Bishop d5
then f7 pawn is going to be in deep deep
trouble
what is almost winning in this position
Roxy 7 does Roxy 7 work
go on continue so there's another target
the king yeah
the d 8 d 8 ranked the back rank rho k 8
Bishop f8 Bishop h6 and black can pretty
much resign
so let's this is a completely winning
position let's say you go rook c8 I go
Bishop d5 you have to defend the f7 pawn
place something like rocket fade and
then after row k1 rugby 7 rock a7 this
point is going to fall one way or the
other
okay completely completely winning and
he is so he black is so losing because
he cannot find counter play he cannot
activate the Queen right he cannot
activate the bishop he cannot activate
the rook so all his pieces are passive
white is completely winning let's go
back that's why I wrote b6 would have
been a bad move my d4 another important
point in the game candidate moves
options we have two of them I want you
guys to find two of them
Bishop takes d4 that's one yes
Bishop d5 that's the second one you're
doing pretty well tonight okay so tell
me the difference why one over the other
take a few minutes try to understand why
one of them would be better than the
other and then we'll vote
anybody eager to give it a shot mm-hmm
you have an idea share it with us
perfect answer yeah Bishop takes d4
gives away too many options he allows
black to pick to take with the Queen
now this pawn is going to become weak
we're going to let's say we're going to
move it nevertheless the d3 porn remains
a weakness and now if you play or Bishop
on d5 what is blacks extra option that
he didn't have before
rook takes d5 giving up the exchange and
then he's going to be down in exchange a
bishop and a pawn for a rook
nevertheless is going to have a lot of
targets to compensate for that he's
going to have the d3 square the d3 pawn
the b3 pawn and he doesn't really have a
lot of weaknesses in the position both a
5 and C five pawns can be easily
defended by the bishop yeah I can put my
bishop on on f8 if you if you threaten
c5 or I can keep it on g7 if you
threaten me 5 so it's going to be very
difficult for white to make any progress
after you after black gives away his
exchange so that's why Bishop takes d4
would have been a big big mistake
well not that big but still pretty
serious mistake Queen c7 Bishop takes
before we have to get a we have to get
rid of that super strong knight on d4 it
takes d4 what now
who has the better position guys and why
we got the opposite car of Bishops right
the bishop on d5 versus the bishop on g7
and we also have all the heavy pieces on
the board
why is white butter it's stuck in there
forever I agree with that also he
doesn't have any targets right the
bishop on d5
has a clear target and that is the f7
point what type what type of position is
this one the character of the position
is it a static or is it a dynamic
position static position
slow slow paced long plants you know
we're not going for the kill
we're not going for the King right now
so try to create a plan based on that
try to understand all your options first
your plan is good but you have better
ways of making it happen
that's a terrible move rookie six I'm
just going to take on these six and then
Rock f7 and then that's going to build
yeah game over no but I mean what
exactly do you want to do with your
let's say I cannot take it
you know let's say I'm not going to take
it what are we doing with that row
kinesics it's kind of like a show-off
you know you're just putting it on the
e6 and be like okay you cannot take it
hmm okay you have a plan okay okay
sure but it's still not the type of
moves that you guys should consider
again it's a static position right
you're not going for the kill
immediately it's a long-term plan
rookie two is one way but you have
another way much better than that
rookie four of course so you have to
similarly look looking moves yeah
rookie two and rookie for the same plan
what's the differentiator between the
two of them and that makes the ricany
form more active yes I mean why only two
when we can go on e for not only six
don't go only six if four is okay also
remember you're you remember your
targets the f7 pawn right so he played
rookie four of course rookie seven by
the way in this type of positions how
many pairs of heavy pieces can we
exchange in this position in particular
actually if we exchange - it's already
too much he's going to be very close to
to getting the draw
and then how can you how can you create
the attack how can you put pressure on
on the targets he's always going to have
the Queen as a defender and we cannot
increase the pressure enough yeah he's
always he's always going to blackmail us
in with exchange of the Queen's and it's
just going to be a draw so we have to
exchange only one pair of rooks that's
the most weaken we can exchange so he
played rook e1 what should black play
hmm
Ruki 8 was the trap I was looking for
you fell for it thank you thank you
yes rookie a rookie ate it it looks like
a good move you're getting ready to
exchange two pair of rooks but now Quint
xe8 comes and game is over
well yeah it's it's pretty much over
Rocky seven would again be a show-off
which is not a good move Quinn take c7
rook takes e7 Bishop takes e7 thank you
very much draw let's go home yeah so now
of course you're not going to do that
you're just going to again bring your
pieces to the attack of the f7 points so
I think Roque it is perfectly fine
you're threatening to go rook e8 King g7
and now something like Roque one okay
seven big big problems for him yeah and
what is black lacking in this position
counter play counter play he doesn't
have absolutely any any ways of getting
to your king he goes to e7 okay he gives
a check okay that's another powerful
kind of idea when you have opposite Cara
bishops if your Bishop is protecting the
king then he doesn't have a way to get
to your king okay so rook e8 would have
been a mistake
he played Bishop f8 what No
the first phase of of our plan has been
achieved mm-hmm Queeny six interesting
move but you're forgetting about the
consequences of that move if you play
Queen a six
what scores you no longer control rugby
eight Luke takes e4 exchange the rooks
draw right so be careful be careful your
one move away from allowing him to to
make a drop all the time in these type
of positions if you let him get his
setup he's going to he's going to
exchange enough pieces he's going to
make the draw you have to improve your
position but in the same time not giving
any any defensive resources
H for absolutely absolutely you're
creating new weaknesses with H four and
this is actually a move that a lot of
good players like to make just scare off
their opponents even if it doesn't do
much you know it's still it's still
asking some questions and it works
wonders believe me so he played h4 of
course King g7 h5 immediately rook d8
what is black threatening
he has a small little idea
these may be trying to play room d7 then
take then play rock e7 and try to
exchange rocks yeah
so white actually took first take now
what what is one piece that is not
actively involved into the attack right
now the Queen
where should we take her Queen d1
absolutely route d6 Queen e2 Bishop f6
continue improving your position guys
it's improved almost to the maximum but
you still have some some ideas that you
could incorporate such as what
kingi - very good you don't fire tonight
very good nice kingi - of course so
what's the point of kimchi - that's a
good defensive idea but there's also an
attacking idea behind it hmm prepare
aloo ke chuan yeah on the H file correct
very good you guys are doing well
rook rook to d7 threatening threatening
rocky 7 of course Queen f3 threatening
h6 thank you Queen d6
take a few minutes and try to play
better than the Grandmaster he actually
failed to see the winning idea in this
position no he still won but but he
allowed his opponent to kind of have a
chance of survival which he didn't take
but you guys need to be as precise as
possible and once again you're only
going to find the correct sequence by by
checking all your candidate moves in
this position
so give me throw at me a few candidate
moves h6 is one of them sure anything
else
Rock h1 absolutely taking control of the
h1 anything else hmm queen g4 yes Queen
g4 is an interesting move let's see
Quincy for the problem you can g4 is
that where are you going with this cling
right yes you can do that also with the
Queen on f3 and the problem is that the
Queen on g4 is not really going anywhere
I'm just I'm still going to play this
move rook h1 and now maybe I'm just
going to start hunting your Queen to try
to exchange it with something like 25
with the idea to go Queen g5 try to
exchange the Queen as soon as possible
if I manage to exchange the Queen then
it's kind of game over there is no more
advantage to it actually I think I'm
making a mistake here
yeah I did blunder h6 King h8 Quincy 8
Queen takes e5 at least upon up so Queen
if I was a bad bad move maybe I'm going
to go Queen d7 also this kind of plays
against your idea your other idea with
the Queen on g4 to go to h3 and try to
put pressure on the h5 so now you cannot
go Queen h3 anymore and you don't have
any active square zone on the H 5 H 4 is
is blocked by the Bishop h3 by the by
the Queen so I have a feeling position
is starting to become very Jewish you
know
okay so let's calculate h 6 H 6 he has
to go King takes H 6 right well he
doesn't have to he can also go king of
King f8 if it goes king G 8 and rook e8
and that's a checkmate right if you go
skiing of faith what could we do
Bishop e6 very good Bishop e6 and let's
look at it take with the pawn most
probably take take on f6 and in the
worst case you can just take upon and
this should be a winning endgame okay so
King f8 is not the critical move the
critical move is just taking the
material taking the pawn two more
minutes okay maybe one more minute
because you guys already have the idea
so h6 King takes h6 Bishop e6 yes and
that's almost game over let's look at it
the point is that the King is going to
be trapped on on the h5 and now you guys
see why King g2 was so important in the
build-up to this whole thing pawn takes
Queen takes f6 rock h1 you cannot defend
against it so completely completely
winning yet he didn't see he was
probably in time trouble it's sometimes
easy to miss this type of this type of
tactics to be honest I would have
thought about Bishop e6 first as a
candidate move and then I would say okay
he takes I play h6 and he can go king f7
and then you kind of forget about this
whole idea but there's just a matter of
move order yeah I would assume that's
why he missed it so he played a move
rookie for
okay now you guys are going to be black
and you guys are going to try to find
some good defensive moves h6 uh-huh
very good very good h6 would have been
would have been a pretty good move or
rookie 7 first look at 4 and now h6
right and now you put your rope here
maybe root goes to g5 white simply
doesn't have a way to make progress
anymore once you blocked him on on the
dark squares so yes big big mistake by
white with rookie for allowing him a lot
of extra chances he played g5 terrible
move terrible terrible move why is it a
terrible move from a conceptual point of
view why is it a bad move you're
weakening a lot of light squares right
so to be honest I have no idea why he
played this move but he did so quite
obviously took advantage immediately h6
okay
let's try to calculate a little bit what
would you guys play f4 you see that's
that's the wrong wrong concept first of
all after after f4 you allow Ruki 7
exchanging the rooks you're also
weakening your own King with that floor
and you're not really creating such such
a difficult to parry threat you're not
threatening anything actually you're
straining to take on g5 and that will
actually just give me more space I will
take with the bishop and I will I would
say thank you for the space so Brooke is
6 bishop takes f7 it's interesting yes
Bishop e6 is also candidate move
absolutely which Bishop e6 let's see
Bishop e6 if I take you take with the
rook Queen f8 and queen g6 right Queen
g6 King h8 room takes f6 and that's
winning but hmm that's the question I
think I think after Bishop e6 black and
simply play rupees 7 and I'm not really
sure if if your attack is still going no
come on guys what is kind of the most
obvious move in this position
something that puts more pressure on
your opponent yes rooty six I want to
say it's a terrible move but I am NOT
going to say it yet it might be an old
king it might be an okay move rookie 6f
take c6 Bishop takes is six and now
you're trying to say that I don't have a
defense against Queen g6 yeah
which one
now let's calculate drunky six because
that's that's that's an important
question she's asking maybe even that
works so Rocky 6f 66 Quincy 6 or Bishop
e6 John Quincy six King f8 Queen takes
f6 row broke up seven let's see Quint x
h6 and this is probably winning yeah
this is it's enough you have a queen you
have a bishop close to his king yes
absolutely absolutely
yeah so Ruki six is one way Rocky six is
one way he had a lot of ways to win in
this position Bishop takes f7 let's look
at it a little bit he cannot take with
the King because of Queen g6 King f8
rocky a checkmate so let's say he takes
with the rook Queen g6 King goes to f8
only move
quint xh6 king goes to G a rocky a Drogo
fate
let's look at it
I think I also have rook g7 in this
position
Queen h8 ruiji 8 only move and I think
we have to repeat the position here so
it kind of becomes unclear you see this
you see that you have some sort of
attack against the king
but you shouldn't go for it because it's
not clear and you have a clear advantage
you're not allowed to go into
complications okay sure
yes rook e8 rook e8 is broke it is very
it's a very obvious attacking move
you're just getting your Muroc on the
eighth-ranked getting closer and closer
to the king so let's calculate that
rocky eight let's say I go rook to e7
Bishop f7 works I think no actually
bishops f7 might not be that good
because of Queen c6 but you have a
checkmate in three moves in that in that
variation yes
Rakhi a drunky seven queen g 6f takes g6
rook g8 king h 7h takes g6 checkmate
yeah so you see when when the pieces are
clustering around the king sauce so
heavily it's something is going to
happen you know
so Rocky 7 allows the pretty cute
checkmate yeah so he's going to go let's
say room da
hmm Ruki six works yeah rookie six is
once again winning Rocky six is once
again winning also bishop takes f7 yeah
Bishop takes f7 as well the point is
that after rook takes eight Queen g6
important you don't want to just have a
point B upon up you want to actually
checkmate today so Queen g6 if King h8
Queen takes h6 checkmate if king of
faith Queen g8 and quintic c8 game over
so rook e8 would have been completely
completely winning once again the
Grandmaster went back rocky one I think
somebody said rook e1 you did yeah you
did play like the Grandmaster though
that's good enough okay
rookies Rocky 7 one now Bishop before
and I'm not going to lie this is
actually quite an easy easy idea to fall
for yeah because you're bringing the the
bishop to e4 you're creating that
battery along the h7 be one diagonal and
you're getting your Queen very close to
the king so it's very attractive but
it's not the best King f8 okay one it's
still winning though it's still winning
rook d7 you're okay five it should be
seven
we shop the 8uc he's tying him up to his
last piece
King g7 and g4 rook c8 slowly slowly
improving his position he's not in a
hurry black simply doesn't have any
counter play so he's going to win no
matter what
rooks e7 rook takes e8 finally finally
it's time to take some action
Queen takes h6 and what is the plan just
push the H Ponyo h6 Bishop g8 h7 once
again black legs counter play that's his
biggest problem in this game
Queen G
I don't know why he was still playing
but I think he finally resigned yeah
King c8 only move Bishop takes at five
Bishop takes eighty-seven completely
completely winning right so this was an
example where we have static positions
okay
there is also examples where we have
dynamic positions and in those we do not
have time to improve our position to the
maximum like we did in this game right
where we have a where we have a dynamic
advantage we have to attack the King and
not give our opponent any breathing room
but when you have a static position
always improve it to the maximum do not
hurry that's kind of the biggest draw
from from from this example